From exciting blockbusters to thought-provoking
indies, 2017 was a great year for films.
And while audiences saw no shortage of great
moments on the big screen, plenty of quality
scenes ended up on the cutting room floor.
Here are the best deleted scenes that you
probably missed in 2017.
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2
Peter Quill may have saved the galaxy a few
times, but that doesn't make him an expert
on Earth's more primitive technology.
This deleted scene from Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2 shows our intergalactic hero trying
to figure out how to work a Zune.
Kraglin, played by Sean Gunn, offers up some
rather choice musical opinions.
"Thin Lizzy is a group I like a lot.
There's a lady on there named Alice Cooper
that I like a lot.
She seems kinda angry, but it kinda like stuff
we felt like when we were kids."
It makes sense that this slow scene would
be cut from the action-heavy outing, but this
funny character moment is still a must-see.
Beauty and the Beast
One of the most bizarre plot points in Disney's
live action Beauty and the Beast has to do
with the castle staff, who have all been turned
into household items because of a curse.
A deleted scene from the recent live-action
remake of the film reveals what happened to
one of the castle's lesser servants.
We first meet the unfortunately named Monsieur
Toilette when Josh Gad's LeFou is scared away
by his gurgling voice.
In a deleted scene, after the curse has been
broken, LeFou notices a dirty, disheveled
man who smells… rather familiar.
"So what are you gonna do now?"
"Brush my teeth."
Disgusting, but also very funny—especially
for fans of toilet humor.
Spider-Man: Homecoming
Even though fresh-faced Tom Holland was outstanding
as Peter Parker, some comic fans were hoping
to see someone else under the mask in Spider-Man:
Homecoming--namely, Miles Morales, the fan
favorite comic book character who became the
Spider-Man of Marvel's Ultimate universe.
In Homecoming, Donald Glover plays Aaron Davis,
who is Miles's uncle in the comics.
"Hey that's gonna dissolve in two hours."
"No, no, no.
Come fix this."
"Two hours.
You deserve that, you're a criminal."
While he merely hints at having a nephew in
the theatrical cut, Davis actually calls him
by name in an awesome deleted scene.
After Spider-Man webs his hand to his car,
Aaron, unable to release himself, eventually
gives in and calls his nephew.
"Yeah, sorry Miles.
I'm not gonna make it.
Yeah I'm just stuck."
Although it's just a small reference, it was
more than enough to send comic book fans into
a tizzy.
Thor: Ragnarok
The Hulk punching Thor was one of the most
memorable moments from The Avengers, and Thor:
Ragnarok almost included a callback to the
scene.
As the team returned to Asgard, the Hulk was
originally supposed to punch Loki out of frame.
"Loki!
Loki's alive!
Can you believe it?
He's up there.
Loki!
Look who it is!"
Considering what happened the last time these
two characters saw each other, it would have
been a hilarious reunion.
Director Taika Waititi revealed in an interview
with Empire that the much-loved moment had
to be cut for time.
"There's so many little things that yeah we've
had to get rid of for time.
And just sometimes it's like we have to choice
between that and Banner falling off the bridge
for the big laugh."
There are still plenty of other hilarious
moments in Thor: Ragnarok, but an Avengers
callback that also cut Loki down to size would
have been a fun addition.
Fingers crossed that it winds up on the DVD.
Get Out
While Rose is clearly a villain in the film
Get Out, one deleted scene may make you question
everything you thought you knew about her.
When Chris, played by Daniel Kaluuya, describes
the Sunken Place to her, Rose reveals that
she, too, has had a similar experience.
"I had the same thing.
She hypnotized me when I was in high school
for stage fright.
And I had the craziest nightmares.
But I just remember thinking, it worked."
Rose easily could have been lying to keep
Chris calm, but it raises the possibility
that she could also have been hypnotized into
cooperating with her family's evil plan.
Considering how it distracts from the film's
message and shows a truly evil character in
a sympathetic new light, it's easy to see
why the scene was cut.
Still, it's interesting to consider the new
questions it would have raised if it had been
kept in the film.
Logan
There were so many deaths in Logan that some
characters, like Stephen Merchant's Caliban,
didn't even get to die on screen.
A deleted scene, however, actually shows the
emotional demise of this fan favorite character.
On the movie's Blu-ray commentary, Director
James Mangold explained that, while he felt
bad for cutting the scene, he didn't want
to call into question why Logan didn't just
take Caliban's body with him like he did for
Professor X.
Although the movie was plenty bleak without
an additional death scene, it would have been
nice to have closure for such an important
character.
Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No
Tales
It may not have reached the seafaring heights
of the franchise's previous films, but Pirates
of the Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No Tales was
an undeniably fun addition to the saga of
Jack Sparrow.
This is most apparent in a deleted scene,
where Johnny Depp's freewheeling pirate finds
himself at odds with Henry, the son of Will
Turner.
"I saw her ankles."
"You'd see a lot more if you'd just keep your
cakehole shut."
The clip begins with Henry threatening Jack
to help him break his father's curse.
In return, Jack helpfully offers the boy some
advice on how to hold his sword before demanding
to be run through.
"Your first murder…
Happy to be a part of it.
Just dont mind all the blood and all the bulging
eyeballs and such."
Of course, having no intention of actually
letting Henry kill him, Jack pulls a gun on
him.
Luckily for audiences, both characters got
the chance to live another day on the high
seas.
The Breakfast Club
It's been more than 30 years since The Breakfast
Club hit theaters, but fans of the original
teenage misfits were treated to a deleted
scene thanks to the film's 2017 Criterion
Collection deluxe reissue.
The sequence kicks off in the girl's bathroom,
with Molly Ringwald's Claire expresses confusion
about Ally Sheedy's Allison and her particular
cleanliness habits.
"You wash your hands but you'll eat food inches
away from a live toilet?"
"I'm sorry, I don't wanna depress you."
Allison stays predictably silent, and then
deliberately drops a potato chip in the sink
before popping it into her mouth.
Although the scene doesn't amount to much,
it's a welcome and fun interaction between
two classic characters.
"This is not correct…"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus, check out this other cool stuff we know
you'll love too!